yes I am HIV is coming out Julian is
funny implies a special Arabic English
moon mission Doyle's is learning
projects learning German translating and
mediating Ahmed is back in his element
just like last summer that's when the
Palestinian refugee from Syria first
arrived at this reception center in the
Eastern German state of terenia a
reunion with the social worker she's
always admired Achmed for his honesty
and initiative for example he's never
held back in complaining about shoddy
sanitation facilities the number of
people staying here has tripled since
the summer to 1800 the mood is tense
sometimes fights break out I can find
out of problems here but I'm I like here
because here you can find out as per
person excellent nationalities different
vision and different culture and you can
also take your experience within three
hours way in the town of brides just 50
people live in this refugee home with
Achmed there's not a lot to do German
lessons and gardening but otherwise it's
a waiting game this is the most
important place for us all of us here
this is the postbox well everyday look
on it if we have a boost for us orla our
boss here is for acceptance about
residents or something like this in this
small Eastern Germantown Ahmed and
Syrian friends stand out refugees don't
always feel welcome but Achmed says he
worries more about religious fanatics
from the Middle East than he does about
neo-nazis he calls his wife hand in
Istanbul every day she also plans to
come to Europe one day well and his
Christian achmad Muslim their
relationship had their lives at risk in
Syria
I'm afraid of they bring these global
problems from the Middle East or from
back here to get me mad recently
received a six-month extension on his
residency permit he's now allowed to
travel and work he knows what he wants I
would like to find that job with the
journalism journalism as i reported
Ahmed Shah javi hopes he'll soon be
recognized as a refugee and then be
reunited with his wife until then all he
can do is wait